[Music]
Hey, I'm Will and with Noble Locksmith
and you're watching my YouTube channel,
Car Key Wizard. I'm an automotive
locksmith and while I definitely don't
know it all, I have learned some tricks
along the way that I hope will help you
while you're out in the field. One thing
you can do to help me out though would
be to subscribe to my channel. And if
you like my videos, leave a comment or
ask a question and I'll get back to you
as soon as I can. I make a lot of
videos, so if there's something you'd
like to learn more about or a video
you'd like to see on a car we're working
on, just let me know in the comments and
I'll put it up as soon as I can. Thanks,
and I hope you enjoy watching my videos.
[Music]
Okay, I have a 2012 Jeep Compass
or I'm sorry, 2020 Jeep Compass Proxy
Key. So, we're obviously looking for a
12 plus 8 or star connector. Took the
world apart. Looking for a star. It's
not behind the radio. It's not on the
passenger side. It's not under here. Um,
there is a 12 plus 8 way up above the
brake pedal. Uh, finally found that and
then found that. don't have my 12 plus 8
on me. I gave it to my other guy last
week. But
for those of you that have the Smart Pro
and don't know
what the other side of the uh or this
it's a what is it? 2012 connector. It is
for the RFH hub which on this compass is
in the rear deck um
under the headliner.
Grab my Smart Pro and put it on the
charge for a minute. Make sure I don't
die in the middle of this.
Just get this hooked up. Give me a sec
here.
So, yeah, here we are in the trunk.
Sorry, fumbling a little bit. It is
200°.
All right, we're going to go 1920
Compass Procs.
Connect the immobilizer.
Ignition is off. Hazards are on.
Read the pin.
26298.
26298. 26298.
Add prox key.
Oh, wrong button.
Yes, I do want to continue.
Found the stored pin code. Good. Because
I already forgot. Yes.
And then I believe we're going to go up
front. Push the buttons.
All right. Place Prox Fobic near the
center console after pressing okay and
press and release lock button once.
Let's get back up here.
Come on.
There it is. Got it. Yay.
Car turns on. Oh, hi.
All right, we're good to go. Program
that key. And this is the compass. So,
it is the uh
what do you call it?
The key with the uh the SIP 22 blade
makes it pretty easy to dig this out of
a drawer. If you don't know what you're
looking at, just look for the SIP 22
blade. That's going to be it. This one
also had a compass on the bag, so I knew
that. But so total number of keys went
up from three to four, and we are good
to go.